[Musique]
un matin comme tous les matins rue
fontaine à pigalle et puis on entend un
facteur me formidable et je crois que ça
vient d'eux du palladium là et j'ai une
petite fille vous savez dans la journée
elle dort parce que la nuit c'est
impossible
elle est toute petite et elle devrait
dormir la nuit est vraiment
elle pleure parce que ça aberrant de
voir
mon mari comme en équipe
oui j'aime danser wii ou es ce que vous
avez contre les danses bien en été je
vais aux canotiers au bord de la marne
et puis en hiver comme pendant réveillon
a rejeté dans un dancing sur ce
boulevard depuis fils était pas mal mais
j'ai jamais été au palladium je ne sais
pas que comment comptent-ils 20 ans
danse vous aider surtout le paso-doble
parce que mon mari dans une ère nouvelle
ben j'aime le twist enfin qui n'est pas
très nouveau maintenant et puis le
rock'n'roll
non je suis curieuse mais j'aimerais
bien apprendre à danser mais jamais
essayé encore parce que je ne sais pas
depuis que j'ai une petite fille je me
trompe l'oeil et
[Musique]
il
ça tape des pieds
c'était impossible je vous dis c'est
impossible
[Musique]
et les locataires se plaignent qu'ils ne
peuvent pas dormir
c'est embêtant ça
[Musique]
derrière cette frénésie un businessman à
peine plus âgé que ce qu'il fait danser
j'aime ça c'est votre vrai nom
oui c'est mon vrai nom c'est mon vrai
prénom je suis français j'ai 23 ans je
suis un homme d'affaires un aventurier g
j'aime le goût du risque et quand on
fait des affaires il faut la voir aussi
je ne suis pas uniquement un homme
d'affaires j'aime réussir c'est un peu
un sport que je fais quand j'entreprends
une affaire je considère ça comme un
sport et j'aime le gagner vous parlez de
risques vous avez l'impression d'avoir
déjà pris des risques
oui j'ai déjà plus des risques jusqu'à à
22 ans j'étais joueur joueurs enfin aux
vraies terme du mot flambeur et je
voulais arriver à avoir une situation
très rapidement j'ai fait pas mal de
métier j'ai toujours abandonnées parce
que c'était trop long pour réussir
j'étais coiffeur et puis gagner toujours
sombre son petit repas quotidiens et
puis l'argent de poche pour le cinéma ça
ne suffisait pas je veux viser beaucoup
plus loin et je voulais j'avais un peu
la maladie du siècle aller très vite et
je voulais faire une affaire kim réussir
et je cherchais je cherchais ma voix et
à force de chercher j'ai trouvé je pense
avoir trouvé quand vous rêvez à des gens
qui représente pour vous la réussite
intégral comme le musicien par exemple
le musicien d'europe que j'ai ici
ils ont tous leur idole ils ont elles
pressent les comédies les hommes
les thomistes il dans les affaires
mes idoles sont aux nazis sont paul
getty fin des gens qui ont réussi qui on
clique sont à des plafonds
extraordinaire vous espérez y atteint en
juin ça c'est vraiment prétentieux si je
vous disais oui mais peut-être c'est ce
que vous souhaitez je le souhaite et je
ferai tout pour le faire quand on dit
tout c'est quoi tout je donnerai le
meilleur de moi même j'ai beaucoup de
volonté pour réussir et je t'ai je garde
la tête sur les épaules je vis très loin
vous auriez m gangster donc cernon
j'aurais voulu être un gangster mais
enfin j'ai admiré des gangsters
j'admirais al capone j'admirais
dillinger j'aimais beaucoup les films de
ceux de ses années 1930 avec paul muni
ce que commencent à fait utile le jazz
raft puis beaucoup d'acteurs comme je
fais j'ai oublié le nom mais enfin les
très grands hommes forts beaux gars et
james cagney bien sûr qu'est ce que vous
pensez du pique nique qui sont chez vous
elle débite mixte qui s'enchaînent le
sont à vrai dire ne sont pas les
beatniks ci sont plutôt apprentis
beatnik s'ils cherchent un peu leur voix
aussi les vrais beatnik sur nos
rencontres on n'en rencontre pas votre
vraiment en continuité au palladium les
vrais beatnik sont les pauvres on les
côtoie à montparnasse au sélect à la
rotonde au dôme
ils ont les cheveux courts et n'ont pas
besoin d'avoir les cheveux longs ceux
qui sont ici se joue un peu la comédie
non il ne joue pas la comédie ils ont un
idéal ils le défendent très bien ils
veulent rester libres ils veulent
devenir libre ce qu'ils ne sont pas
veulent le devenir
ils ont des problèmes des problèmes ce
sont pour la plupart des garçons 10
issus de familles pauvres s'ils avaient
fait s'il avait fallu qu'ils travaillent
j'aurais travaillé à l'usiné et leur
paie il fallait la donner à leurs
parents leur part on ne rompt pas
souvent donné le bon exemple
ils ont eu des scènes de ménages et ça
les a là c'est parce que le peu qu'il
leur restait de leur paye ne suffisait
pas pour pour le revoir leur liberté
parce que le lendemain il retournait à
l'uci de l'horizon non humains un jour
ils ont voulu ou vend la rue voir la
liberté
ces personnes qui sont là en face d'où
je viens a franchement non
non c'est pas parce que c'est le
monsieur en costume ça mais le fait
qu'il faudra qu'un jour je rentre chez
moi et que je vive en fin de compte cet
ennui continue continue ça vraiment ceux
ci tories c'est vrai vous vous sembliez
quand vous rentrez chez vous ils ne
peuvent pas le savoir ils n'ont pas mon
âge et moi quand je rentre chez moi je
n'éprouve aucun ennui ça ils ne seront
plus tard j'espère qu'ils sont heureux
comme moi je suis jeune transports en
commun dans un thriller où elle répond
tous des frères qu'est ce qui va arriver
dans la nuit
qu'est ce qui va arriver après ça je
peux pas savoir maintenant des chats
promeyrat qu'est ce qu'ils arrivent cela
me dérange pas ce qu'il ya
yves france mais vous n'y pensez jamais
vous vivez au jour le jour
non je pense pas je mens jamais
[Musique]
j'attends
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]